we're learning new details of an
extraordinary claim that Amazon CEO Jeff
Bezos phone was hacked by Saudi Arabia
The Guardian reports an investigation
ordered by Bezos blames the hacking on a
personal message that apparently came
from Saudi Crown Prince Mohammed bin
Salman the United Nations is also
weighing in today
Errol Barnett is following this era what
do we know about how this happened
well good morning that UN report you
mentioned is expected to validate
findings that Bezos apparently received
a malware infected video file from a
whatsapp account reportedly belonging to
Saudi Crown Prince Mohammed bin Salman
that was then used to infiltrate bezos's
personal phone now the Saudi embassy
calls these claims absurd but the
allegations raise serious questions
about what the kingdom wanted would
Bezos has information and how it used it
according to the Financial Times the
hacks routes trace back to Bezos and bin
Salman exchanging phone numbers in Los
Angeles weeks later says Britain's the
Guardian paper Bezos and the crown
prince were engaged in a seemingly
friendly whatsapp exchange when bin
Salman sent an unsolicited malware
infected file it's unclear what
information was then taken questions
about who has access to the tech
executives phone were first raised last
year after the National Enquirer leaked
photos and intimate text messages
between the then married Bezos and
former TV anchor Lauren Sanchez with
whom he was having an affair The
Inquirer said Sanchez's brother Michael
was the original source of the
information but in a blog post a month
after the scandal Bezos who also owns
the Washington Post suggested the photos
leaked by The Enquirer were obtained
illegally through its publishers
connection to the Saudi government in an
op-ed for The Daily Beast Bezos is
security consultant that's Gavin de
Becker confirmed the Saudi government
had access to bezos's phone and gained
private information he said the
government was intent on harming Jeff
Bezos since the post began its
relentless coverage of the murder of one
of its colonists critical of the Saudi
Kingdom
Jamal Khashoggi was killed at the Saudi
consulate in Istanbul five months after
the alleged hack US officials tell CBS
News that the murder was likely ordered
by the crown prince CBS evening news
anchor and managing editor Norah
O'Donnell spoke to him last September
did you order the murder of Jamal
khashoggi penis like that absolutely not
this was a heinous crime but I take full
responsibility as a leader in Saudi
Arabia especially since it was committed
by individuals working for the Saudi
government NBS is role a personal role
in potentially compromising jeff bezos
no I think raises additional questions
about mbss defense of this Joji murder
that it was simply rogue actors within
his state Andrew Miller of the
washington-based think tank project on
Middle East Democracy believes the
Washington Post's aggressive reporting
on Jamarcus Yogi's murder put a target
on bezos's back that's the way things
work in Saudi Arabia that's the way
things work in NBS is world it was a
clear attempt to blackmail Bezos into
changing Washington Post coverage and
relieving scrutiny on Mohammed bin
Salman reckless actions CBS News has
learned that the information being
released by the United Nations will be
part of a larger report expected to be
published later this year on
extrajudicial killings The Washington
Post has not commented to CBS News we've
also reached out to Amazon and Jeff
Bezos his team and have not yet heard
back I tell you what it raises a lot of
questions but old paper and pen for
communication it may be the best way
forward the the reverberations on this
will be huge if you can hack the
wealthiest man in the world's phone
Silicon Valley very interested to know
how this happened
and not to mention there's another
person who MBS is reportedly what's that
buddies with and that's president
Trump's son-in-law advisor Jared Kushner
so there's much more to this story a lot
of vulnerability there right all right
Errol thank you very much
you